[Music]
i grew up in mississippi
in my neighborhood everyone was black
day to day i didn't see overt signs of
segregation
but when i went uptown
it was a different story
there's no bus service here anymore
but when i was a boy
i was only allowed into
one of these doors
one said white
one said color
as a kid
when you're confronted
with an evil like racism
your first reaction is confusion
why does this exist
where does it come from
[Music]
for all of our capacity to do good
the urge to do evil has plagued human
history
if you believe we live in a world under
divine control
why should evil exist at all
so i'm going on a journey
to try to understand why evil exists i
know what you did my question is can you
tell me why
to discover how it invades our lives
people who believe that they are
possessed by an evil spirit can come
here how evil
first stole our hearts if you're lying
or doing anything evil your heart gets
heavy and with a heavy heart you're not
going to go to heaven
and i'll see how some religions train us
to fight the devil you have two
mentalities one is good and one is bad
to turn the darkness
i did some incredibly terrible things
into light
you represent the hope of the world
[Music]
to understand why evil exists
we have to know where it comes from
some faiths see it as an unseen force
that pervades the entire world
demons that lurk in the darkness
for christianity
it could be the devil himself
or
is evil something that comes from inside
us
so i'm traveling to a maximum security
prison
to meet a man you could call
evil incarnate
king you ever come
face to face with evil i've met some
people who've done some very bad things
neuroscientist dr kent kiel is trying to
pinpoint the source of evil
inside the brains of psychopathic
killers
i wanted to try to understand why people
do
really bad things how to
how to help prevent it someday
thank you
[Music]
i'm about to meet one of dr kiel's most
notorious subjects
he's serving a life sentence here
his attorney tells me this man raped
more than two dozen women
and murdered three
he's been in jail
almost since he was a teenager except
for very short spurts where when he
would get out of jail he would go back
to the same behavior
of raping and eventually it evolved into
murder did
he confess to these he confessed all of
them
i'm not going to show you his face
because i don't want to give any more
notoriety to the man who committed these
atrocities
but i want to know
what can make someone do what he
did you know who i am yes
i know what you did
my question is can you tell me why
it was a spur-of-the-moment thing each
time
i didn't have any plan to go out and
snatch anybody
commit any sexual violence against
anybody
i had a desire an
impulse and
i wasn't able
to stop myself from acting on the
impulse
let me ask you
about what age
did you
start
i think when i was 21 and 22
i was out looking for something to steal
and i just spotted
a teacher
who had stayed late
so i decided to rob her kidnapper and
rape her
i just pulled over on an access road and
she fought back
slipped through the door
and i just turned around and
took off
when did you first kill
going on 27. i was going out to
committee burglary
and
the crime map
kidnapped raped and murdered
i'm looking for the correct term
it isn't guilt it's remorse remorse
did you ever experience that that you
know of
i don't see emotions like everybody else
um i don't feel them
uh
there was no
remorse
i think that
i'm not wired the same as everybody else
so can't yeah
is this psychopathic
in psychiatry we have a way of assessing
what we call psychopathy or psychopathic
personality disorder and the lack of
empathy the impulse control the poor
planning he scores you know in the 99th
percentile
what makes a person evil
kent has scanned the brains of 800
psychopathic criminals
this prisoner is the most extreme case
he's ever seen
so this is a standard mri scan looks
pretty normal when you run through the
mri scan but what we did is quantify all
the different areas of his brain and to
try to understand how dense are they how
strong are they basically this area of
the orbital frontal cortex it's very
important for the formation of
personality for the control of impulses
for
regulating behavior these three bars
that i show here this is the average
inmate this is other individuals that we
call psychopaths in the red bar and you
can see that he's he's really reduced he
really does have a different brain and
so he he really does fit that 99th
percentile he's you know one in a
million actually
100 million he's very rare
you've been in prison now for
about 30 years
yep
a long time what if i said
i have a way
to get you out would you want to go
i'd want to go
but since i did commit those crime i
still have that
capacity
society wouldn't be safe i don't have
the same controls as you do or somebody
else does
this is an evil man
evil personified
neuroscientists say that his behavior is
a result of
bad neural wiring
but the question is
even so
does he not still
have a choice
can he choose
not to commit
a heinous crime
psychopaths
are at the extreme of human behavior
but we all face the choice to do good or
do evil
and for thousands of years
we battled those urges
i've come to luxon capital of ancient
egypt
egyptologist selena ephram is going to
show me one of the oldest depictions of
our struggle to choose between good and
evil
so right over there
yes
all the east into the park on the other
side of the nile the east of the nile
was always the land of the living
and then over here
you have the land of the dead
on the west literally
all those tombs
yep
all of those are tombs and i want to
show you one in particular
these are the tombs of the nobles
just around the corner from the valley
of the kings where tutankhamun was
buried more than three millennia ago
so here's the tomb of menna
here we go
oh
oh
look at that there we are
that's mena over there
and he was described for the god amun
and he oversaw the lands of the god amun
and also over here you can see this big
harvest
that he's checking out it's great
they're harvesting the wheat
this artwork is 3
500 years old yup
1370 bc
and it hasn't been touched up those are
his scribes he's overseeing
the scribes precisely
[Music]
and
can i get back to the states i'm going
to be a hieroglyphic expert you are
indeed now let me show you
a little something
about how mena gets to go to the
afterlife
menace tomb includes a remarkable
feature that selima tells me i have to
see
a scene where mena would be judged on
the balance of good and evil he had done
this is all funerary procession okay
you can see his coffin being brought
here
that's his coffin there that's his
coffin
and then
he's brought here finally
in front of the guard osiris
this is mina
and then here you have complete
innovation
this is the first time you ever see this
really in a private tomb
and that is
the weighing of the heart scene
and here he is being judged
to see if he was good or if he was evil
in front of osiris the god of the
underworld
mena's heart is weighed against the
goddess of truth not
while thoth her husband writes down the
judgment
so it's almost as if it's a cliff note
for him
cliff notes
so if you're lying or stealing or
cheating or doing anything evil the
whole thing is the fact that it reflects
on your way it's on your heart your
heart gets heavy
i have a heavy heart
yes and with a heavy heart you're not
going to go to heaven that's right you
won't be able to have liftoff basically
just well put
so in this depiction
his heart is indeed in balance
right
right so he's cool
totally cool all right
good to go into the afterlife
you would think that that would be the
beginning at least somehow
of the judeo-christian
ethic as it were
in terms of good and evil in that
basically i think that modern religion
has its roots in this idea of morality
and
that anything bad you do is reflected
and can be judged in some way the
egyptians were very literal they said
you can judge it by your heart
but even now when you know you can say
he is pure of heart it means he's a good
person right
in the centuries after manna
the idea of eternal reward for turning
one's back on evil spread throughout
egyptian society
and from there
it may have fed into judaism
christianity
and islam
[Music]
wearing of the heart assumes that fear
of consequences is the only thing that
keeps us on a righteous path
which makes me wonder
are we inherently good
are inherently evil
in fact that question is at the very
root of the christian faith
the early leaders of the church trace
our tendency to sin
back to adam and eve who ate the
forbidden fruit
original sin
i've come to meet baptist reverend and
theologian cutter calloway to find out
whether original sin means we are all
evil at heart
hey pleasure to meet you thank you
have a seat thank you
or which book were you reading
the first few chapters of genesis that
is exactly what i want to talk about and
what i want to talk about
is
sin
what
is
original sin
well it's a good question
the christian tradition
kind of coined original sin and some
primal desire uh that we all have that's
a very basic human urge or impulse
because adam sent
that original sin was passed on from one
generation to the next
perpetuated generation after generation
after generation
i have recently spent some time
with a person who we could say
it personifies
evil and you just say why did
you do these things and he would say
i just felt like i'm beyond that i don't
know
now that's inherent
evil isn't it
what you saw you could name that as a
sort of demonic thing
this is demonic
it's demonic but i think it's important
for us
um
to acknowledge that
that there is a little bit of him in all
of us there's something inherent um in
us that seems to
bend itself towards uh death and
violence is there a devil or is that
just a metaphor
uh it is a metaphor uh and also
the devil is real
there's a lot of different forms you
know devils with pitchforks to goblins
and ghouls etc
in the new testament you even get jesus
interacting with satan and yet at the
same time you have jesus
talking to one of his disciples
and saying at one point get behind me
satan
so it seems even jesus is dealing with
both a
an actual presence what we might say is
a personified evil and at the same time
that we can be satanic uh demonic in in
our own
desire to steer away from what god wants
we are born with the capacity for evil
inside us
most of us struggle our whole lives to
resist the temptation to do wrong
but there could be another source of
evil in our lives
the people who brought us into this
world
my dad was a alcoholic whether they are
living
or dead
does evil exist in the world is it
because we all have evil inside us
or does it come from somewhere else
[Music]
i've traveled to india to understand
what hindus believe is the source of
evil
the unhappy souls
of their
ancestors i'm in the city of varanasi to
visit the temple of tishash mochan where
exorcisms go on all day long
[Music]
my guide very nicely resident and
educator b.a media
introduces me to the head priest
and to see the goblin
or pishash
who is said to live here
so there was a goblin for 15 years was
wandering around
in pain
so he finally prayed to shiva
the great hindu god shiva
puts the goblin through a purifying
ritual which ends with a dip in the
nearby pond
that instantly cures him of his disease
in return
shiva orders the goblin to protect
people near the pond from any other evil
spirits
now shiva asked
okay you're cured so you're going to
help all the people who suffer being
possessed by evil
this is a benign goblin yes he's a
benign
now this pond has become a place of
healing
a haven for people who feel their lives
are haunted by an evil presence
so here you look at the water it's
brackish but people believe that
something is going to
term for it
yeah so you know the uh typical theme is
water cleanses everything okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy that
hindus believe that when someone's death
is traumatic or unhappy their soul can
become angry and haunt the lives of
their children or other relatives
this can cause mental or physical
illness even financial troubles
the correct rituals however
can liberate the unhappy soul
and free the living
[Music]
what's going on over there
he's exercising yes
[Music]
[Music]
response either screams or response in
terms
or they have spasm
and then finally they believe that it's
released
most of the people who come here don't
need a full-on exorcism like this man
the shukla family are typical clients
they are having money troubles and they
worry that the spirits of their
ancestors may be the cause
this is a departure
for the spirit that is wandering around
what gives you the impression what makes
one think of
my parents spirits are not settled
i think personal troubles
then something is causing them trouble
whenever there's a financial loss in the
family and frequent sicknesses bad
dreams and
so everything is associated with this
position
to make their ancestor spirits happy
the shuklas must prepare them a good
meal
one that is blessed by the priest
they offer
the honey clarified butter banana fruits
and everything
so this will be offered to
dead soul which is going to eat the food
so this should be a special meal
after receiving all the food they offer
a lamp and an umbrella and a pair of
shoes
so here every deported soldiers treated
like a real human being uh it's welcomed
if the spirit is treated like a real
human being
the ancestors received what they need
for their journey in the afterlife
after the shoot was off of the food to
the sacred pond
and nail a coin to this holy tree
[Music]
the unhappy souls of their ancestors are
set free
and the shadow of evil
lifts
in christianity
you've got the devil and you've got god
you've got good good evil uh
don't seem to have that going on
in
hinduism in hinduism there's no
dichotomy between
good and evil the same person can become
good and evil
in a temple like this even the evilness
treated very respectfully and is treated
caringly
that's very interesting
very interesting concept because i think
it sort of frees us up to be better oh
yeah
yeah
there's always at the end the hope
the hope that even the evil can be
liberated
and evil can be purified like taking a
dip into the pond
[Music]
so i've been watching
[Music]
people in these temples i mean crowds of
people doing ritual to ritual trying to
stay in good graces of their ancestors
but the thing about it is
evil is not spurned
evil is thought of as a spirit that
needs help
just
needs to find peace
cool
hindus want to guide evil into becoming
good
that idea is also the basis of another
faith
one of the oldest and most influential
religions in the world
but it's one most of us have never heard
of
it's called
zoroastrianism
i've come to orange county california to
meet the president of the temple here
arman ariane
welcome to california's zoroastrian
center
thank you
zoroastrianism began 3
500 years ago
in ancient iran
the central symbol of the faith
is fire
today there are just a few small pockets
of zoroastrians around the world
mostly in india and iran
but some are here in california
this is the fire temple
and this fire is always going this is a
symbol of zoroastrianism the fire is
always going
it represents enlightenment
the more you are aware of this world of
ours the more you know what's ahead the
better decisions you can make
it's kind of like you're walking with a
flashlight in your hand yeah
the brighter the light in your life
that's right how does that tie in
to
zoroastrian belief
in
the separation of good and evil
in this zarathustra's school of thought
you have two mentalities which were
translated by westerners as
spirits one is good and one is bad they
are principles they are
a way of behaving
so the zoroastrian motto is good
thoughts good words and good deeds
zoroastrianism is a religion focused on
defeating evil
zoroastrian priests wear clean white
robes
which like their sacred flame represent
enlightenment
the path away from evil
prayers are still said in the ancient
iranian language avestan
which was spoken by its founder
zoro astor
professor of religion gregory reilly
has been studying how zoroastrian
beliefs shaped judaism and christianity
and how they gave birth to the idea of
the devil
zoroastrianism predates the abrahamic
religions that's right yeah zoroaster
postulated that to defeat evil in the
world we're going to have to have a
cataclysmic battle
and god and the devil are going to fight
it out
that's new testament that's not in zero
australia yes it is or else
yeah
and if you go to the great
massive religions around there's no
devil the israelites they lived without
a devil until they're in babylon
the jews met zoroastrianism and they
began to assimilate ideas
they come back and the devil begins to
appear in jewish literature these ideas
about the devil having caused that evil
and
those things start to work on people so
by the time we get to to jesus's day
they've actually
created a name for the devil bails the
ball if you've heard that one yeah it's
got few of them yeah
so the great competitor of jesus in our
new testament gospels this is now a new
take that's right jews make it their own
christians make it their own
islam makes it their own
but just as the idea of the devil in
christianity evolved from ancient
beliefs modern zoroastrianism has
evolved too for many zoroastrians the
devil is no longer a real demonic figure
it's an internal combatant
the struggle between good and evil is
one that takes place in the mind
so the zoroastrian motto is good
thoughts good words and good deeds and
the order is very important because you
start with a thought
you you talk it with a mentor before you
take any actions this way you don't get
yourself in trouble
and there is no
satan there was no
devil something outside influencing us
right meaning
therefore
that
god is resident
in each of us each of us
school of thought is not something in
the past or future but what we can do at
this very time
all our problems
in the world
are man-made
therefore they should be solved by matt
can be
blame it
on a supernatural force
is not a zoroastrian notion right
sorry austrians believe that good and
evil exists within us all
and
we must make the choice
for good
each one of us
has to purge evil from within us
every day
by
doing good
doing the right thing
purging the world of evil is not the
work of
messiahs kings
prophets
it's the work of each one of us
may we
taylor
butcher
salesman
actor
whoever we are
i like that
but is it really possible to conquer
evil without the threat of a real devil
without the threat of eternal punishment
[Music]
in new zealand psychologist jesse bering
believes we need supernatural beings to
keep us on the right track
are you guys ready to play a game
jesse devised an experiment to test his
theory
all right why don't you guys make a
circle
and sit in front of me here and i'll go
over the rules for you
so you see this this piece of tape the
first rule is that you can't step
over the line
the second rule
is that you've got to throw
with your back
to the dartboard
so you can kind of go like this and do
the best that you can
oh see
oh
not that easy is it
you're gonna be playing this game one at
a time and the person that gets the most
uh points on the dartboard
gets a very special prize
at the end of the day
all right we'll see you guys in a little
bit
jessie watches through hidden cameras to
see if the children cheat
so here we've got a little boy and you
can almost see
the machinations in his mind
let's see if he does it
you can hardly blame a six-year-old
for doing that he really wants the prize
and he thinks he can get away with it
and
it's the normal child response
this little girl
look at her she's going right over the
line
and she's putting it several balls on on
the board itself and she's checking now
to see if anybody's actually
watching her could see what she's just
done
they think they're alone in the room and
why not cheat if you can get away with
it nobody's watching
but what if someone was watching
jesse runs the exact same experiment on
a new group of children
and an invisible supernatural being
now before we begin i wanted to
introduce you guys to somebody really
special who's in the room with us right
now
now her name is princess alice
have any of you ever heard of princess
alice before she's a very friendly
magical princess and she's got a very
special ability she can make herself
invisible
princess alice is sitting in that chair
right now
so you guys go upstairs for now
and then we're gonna bring you each down
individually to play the game
with the kids believing they're under
the gaze of an invisible princess
jesse sees something remarkable
now this little girl she's been pretty
good so far
clearly not interested in breaking the
rules
so here we've got a little girl and
she's actually touching the chair to see
if maybe she can feel princess alice
sitting there
oh she's saying princess alice so she's
clearly not cheating here
that's the power of belief you know
these kids have never heard of her
before but all of a sudden she becomes
real in their minds
results are always the same so what
we've seen after testing hundreds of
kids with this study is that kids that
are told that princess alice is in the
room with them when they're left alone
are significantly less likely to cheat
she's doing the same thing that any
supernatural agent or god would do in a
given society she is watching them she
cares about their social behavior and
ultimately at least the implicit
assumption is that somehow she will act
if they violate one of the rules
jesse's research suggests that we need
to believe we're being watched to
eliminate selfish behavior
to keep evil in check
so the proverbial question is would you
rob a bank if you thought that nobody
could possibly know that you've done
that
and i think if we're honest with
ourselves many of us would walk in there
and actually take all that currency
then all seeing all knowing all-powerful
interventionist moralistic deity that
helps steer people
in the direction of
good behavior
the reward of heaven
and the threat of eternal punishment in
hell
keep us on the right track
but what about those who have succumbed
to evil
can faith lead us to redemption
or does evil mark us for life
i'm traveling the world
to discover why people believe evil
exists
christians jews and muslims believe it's
part of the human condition
to be tempted to do wrong
many faiths urge us to fight temptation
to put the greater good ahead of our
self-interest but can we actually rid
ourselves of evil
in sarnath india
i witness how tibetan buddhists purge
themselves of evil thoughts
[Music]
the monks here at the vajravidya
monastery perform daily chanting rituals
the music puts them in a meditative
state of mind
[Music]
buddhists believe the urge to do evil
stems from our ignorance of how our
minds work
the ritual helps these young monks
locate the source of those bad thoughts
[Music]
so that they can understand their cause
and overcome them
but not everyone wants to fight their
inner demons
there are plenty of people who seem to
be hell-bent on doing bad things
is there any way to change them
i've asked kent kiel the neuroscientist
who studies psychopaths to meet me again
i want to know if his brain scans give
us a way to combat
evil i mean we always accept evil as
there it is it just is there's nothing
to do about it
but could these brands can be used maybe
to
intercept some young people before they
get going on this i think they can when
we understand
the systems of the brain that are
different in people who commit these bad
crimes
it gives us an opportunity to try to
develop a treatment for that it's like
if you you know if i injure my arm and
my this muscle gets atrophied just like
these certain areas of their brain are
atrophied i might be able to develop a
treatment program that remediates that
atrophy and fix it
at about what age
range would you think as an expert you
would have to start looking
following sandy hook elementary school
shootings in the united states we
were asked by the parents who lost their
children there to to do that study to
analyze brains of kids that we've
studied who've killed other people
versus
kids in prison who have not and when we
did that analysis i wasn't sure that we
would find anything that different
but we really did
certain areas of the temporal lobes of
the emotional areas of the brain
were underdeveloped or they hadn't
achieved a normal development so when
you say kids what are you talking about
are you talking about 14 15 16. yeah so
that's the kids we were working with
unfortunately those kids had killed
about 16 people
the neuroscience today is about 10 11 12
we think that we can help identify and
separate kids that are problems versus
kids that are just disruptive and are
going to grow out of it if you were a
judge and you wanted to know is this a
high-risk kid or a low-risk kid we could
say this there's a high-risk kid
we now have a tool that can help us
understand or can help predict
the worst type of things that we all
want to prevent a homicide to death
what we really want to be able to do is
get better and better at predicting and
then that'll help us be better and
better at preventing
[Music]
science may help identify those who are
most prone to evil
but how do you turn your back on a life
of evil
i've come to los angeles to meet a man
who wiped all trace of evil from his
life all right buddy you are all done
uh i'm looking for brian brian whitener
morgan freeman brad wagner how are you
i'm very well indeed very well how are
you i'm doing well sir tell me something
about yourself i hear terrible things
well for 16 years i was a neo-nazi
skinhead
a neo-nazi skinhead yes sir i was in uh
multiple skinhead gangs i was an
enforcer and one did uh some incredibly
terrible things to a lot of undeserving
people
i was an evil person
i wanted to hurt the world
uh that's all i wanted to do i was i i
had a sense of just
utter destruction for everybody that was
that was my driving goal
well let me ask you how did you get to
the street why were you on the street i
fell in with a gang basically is what
happened i fell in with the wrong people
i was 14 years old and i was running the
streets these guys gave me a place to
stay the beer made me feel accepted and
wanted
after about my 10th year i kind of
realized this is a subculture of of
degenerates i realized
i'm not superior to anybody i in fact i
was pretty well a lower form of humanity
you know okay now we're up to 10 years
after you've been running around with
these
people and you've had a
an epiphany
tell me a little bit about that some
really
just magical things just kind of
happened out of nowhere like
well i went to a skinhead concert in
2005
and i met a woman there
and uh by the january of 2006 we got
married
by february she was pregnant it was i
had to start taking a hard look at
what i was doing with myself i'm
bringing this child into a world
and um told him i can't do this anymore
i'm done i got i got to take care of my
son
so during that time when i made the
change
on the inside i actually had to make a
physical change on the outside how is
that let me show you
that is what i used to look like i mean
my neck was completely sleeved out my
face was sleeved out i looked the part i
couldn't escape the way i looked on the
outside even though i had already
changed on the inside
i got in contact with the southern
poverty law center
they actually uh set it up to where
i was able to get the tattoos taken off
my face
well now
i mean i can see
little
indications of star that
more like you were maybe in a
fight at some point and it healed up it
looked like you had all this stuff
removed how long a process was that
um it took about two and a half years
there was 25 26 treatments something
like that um every two weeks i was
getting
getting lasers at it was uh ungodly
excruciating my face was constantly
swollen i looked like the elephant man
it was it was bad time and here's
actually a picture of me during the
process
that looked like you got punched in the
eye yes it looks like i was a bad boxer
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
sort of like
paying dues
i very much looked at it as a penance
actually yes okay i took the pain to
as a reminder that i've caused enough so
i might as well have some
can you describe to me your sense
of yourself in those times
in terms of
evil
looking back
i had absolutely no remorse i was
borderline sociopathic i had no feelings
i wanted to hurt the world
when i was going through the tattoo
removal i i found god
i before that i was a pagan and uh
my life was always dark i always had a
whole hole in my soul i guess would be
the best way to put that i don't know
exactly what his name is or if it's even
judeo-christian there is a godly
presence in the universe and it made
itself known to me
it may help me realize that
there is good and evil in all of us and
my goal now is basically when i just
leave this world a better place than
when i got into it you know just try to
be a good person that's all i can do and
i hope that's good enough
we have
sometimes
thoughts that evil is just existing
there's no hope
but you represent the hope of the world
that transformation that complete
transformation
that you yourself made
absolutely
and for you and to be able to
just completely turn yourself around
like that it's very very encouraging
and
i'm honored to talk to you
thank you
well i gotta tell you something i just
i've been noticing
you're a good-looking man well thank you
so are you by the way
[Laughter]
the outward stains of brian's past have
been wiped away
but i'm struck by the astonishing
difference in his two lives on the
inside
that was evil in his heart
his admission
deep and remorseless
but he says
the birth of his son
an adawning belief in god is what purged
him of evil
if brian can do that
gives us hope
that people can change
evil can be contained
this hope
is at the core of the christian faith
we have gathered today on this riverbank
to perform one of the oldest traditions
in our faith
that of baptism
people sin
but those sins
can be washed away we follow jesus
example today
as we baptize austin
katie
abby norman and chris
[Music]
these five do this
as a sign of repentance and forgiveness
of sin
[Music]
baptism points the direction to where we
are headed
and it's a new start
on life
the bible tells us adam and eve knew no
evil
until they ate the forbidden fruit
almost every fate tells the story of how
evil begins
whether we believe it comes from unhappy
souls
the devil himself
or the devil within
we all eventually come face to face with
evil
but i think we need to know evil because
in spite of all the suffering it causes
it drives us to do good
without evil
how would we have ever developed our
unique human characteristics
the ability to express kindness
mercy
forgiveness
[Music]
[Music]
you